today i have another beautiful
example really a perfect example of
these attempts to play
hardball with joe biden's press
secretary jenn
saki and it is not going well and this
one
isn't just fox news's peter ducey saying
something obviously belligerent this is
a reporter actually trying to make
something that is not controversial
controversial
the question is from owen jensen who is
a reporter for the religious channel
ewtn
owen wants uh to know how can we be sure
that covid's stimulus money in the
planned
proposed 1.9 trillion dollar coveted
relief bill
how can we be sure that none of that
money will go
towards abortions now jenn saki does
something smart
she asks well what specific sections
are you even referring to where money
could go to abortion
let's listen and then discuss go ahead
in the back yeah good afternoon
owen jensen ewtn global catholic network
so regarding the american rescue plan
groups like
pro-life groups including the susan b
anthony list very concerned that
millions of u.s taxpayer dollars
will go to the abortion industry in
violation of the hyde amendment
we know where president biden stands on
the hyde amendment but that being said
can this administration right now
guarantee if the american rescue plan is
passed
that no taxpayer dollars will go to the
abortion industry which component of the
american rescue plan are you referring
to
i pull it up right here a 50 million
dollar
funding increase for the title 10
program
uh 750 million dollars for global health
activities and billions in funding for
community health centers without
applying the height amendment
well the president's uh view on the
height amendment is well
known as you have stated in your
question he also believes that community
health centers
are a key
part of addressing the pandemic of
ensuring that people in communities
have access to vaccines have access to
treatment and information about uh about
making sure they're healthy and their
loved ones are healthy so that remains a
priority to the president
he's shared his view on the hyde
amendment i don't think i have anything
new for you
so jen saki's later part of the answer
is sort of okay but it's her earlier
question that's key she asks
what parts of covid relief are you
referring to
and the reporter mentions title 10
global health initiatives
and funding for community health centers
now two of those we can just dismiss out
of hand because there's no evidence they
don't make sense
he says does the money for global health
initiatives maybe go towards abortions
there's no reason to think that that's
the case does the money for community
health centers maybe go towards
abortions
absent some reason to believe that that
funding would go towards abortion i
think there's no reason
to explore those any further but the
interesting one is title 10.
title 10 is a federal grant program
that's related
it's related to family planning that's
true uh
and it is part of the program that no
title 10 money
goes to abortion directly it is
true that because title 10 provides
money for contraception and family
planning
it reduces pregnancies and thus it
reduces the number of people
seeking abortions and again some people
might say well listen title 10
allows money to go to planned parenthood
and planned parenthood
does abortions but again
the the law is planned parenthood
can't use title 10 money to fund
abortions
so this is the same tired talking a
point a talking point
about federal funds for abortion that
religious media
and republican politicians love to trot
out whenever the president is a democrat
when there actually isn't anything to
discuss
title 10 money can't go towards
abortions there's no reason to think
that if the title 10 money is in coveted
relief
it would be any different than anything
else now one last bonus clip for you
from yesterday's briefing just another
silly question
a reporter tries to also play hardball
with jen
saki because joe biden's planned address
to a joint session of congress is
happening in march not in february as
some initially thought
and it just kind of goes nowhere sorry
just wanted to follow up on
the president's appearance before a
joint session of congress in his prime
time
address last month in january reading
from prepared remarks he said
next month in my first appearance for a
joint session i will lay out my
buildback better plan
so it feels like he did say it was going
to be in february well
what i was referring to is there was
reporting on february 23rd and i don't
know where that date came from which has
never been inaccurate so
it was the february 23rd wasn't just an
inaccurate date no one's fault it just
it just was and it created some
confusion so i was just trying to
clarify it
uh obviously the president looks forward
to speaking to a joint session we just
don't have a date yet for when
that will be jen saki continuing to just
be kind of like the mom
who's frustrated but trying to remain
patient
with her kids maybe it's just a
confusion
we're not blaming anybody the address by
joe biden will be in march it's
not a big deal and there are rumors of
course from
from uh washington that joe biden
doesn't want to do that address until
coveted relief
is passed and i would certainly
understand that because the longer it
goes without passing covet relief
the more of a the more of an early stain
that that will be on the biden
presidency it's time to pass it
it's time to pass it i said it yesterday
i said it the day before
i'm not going to keep going on and on
but it is time to pass covet relief
remember during their first year in
office
presidents typically don't do a state of
the union but they will sometimes do
a joint address before the house and
senate not
called a state of the union it could be
really at any time
and i am looking forward to seeing joe
biden's in march
but um really trying to create a
controversy where there isn't one
after the break we are going to talk
about the latest
fabricated scandal from right-wing media
about the biden administration this one
is so stupid
that it really shows you the degree to
which the right is desperate to create
these scandalous narratives we'll take a
quick break we'll do that soon
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
s h masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other
protective gear for covid 19 and they're
giving my audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell and that's actually
why i reached out to them
about being a sponsor i've tried tons of
different face masks this year like many
of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap they
also have disposable cloth masks which
are really comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are
very reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping is
free on orders over a hundred and fifty
dollars you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david